I want to talk about nonlinear divisors
you remember which part of our working
are the divisors right it's this guy
here that's a divisor and we use the
same thing okay anyway so those are the
divisors there are things you're
dividing by so far for the sake of
simplicity you've noticed every time
I've given you linear ones
okay linear divisors but you don't have
to divide by linear numbers any more
than you have to divide by units all the
time right I could divide by tens as
well okay it obviously becomes a little
more complicated because now you have to
think or how many 27s fit in here or
here or here right so it takes more men
to work but there's no reason why it
can't be done
okay so what we'll do is let's think
let's go back to the original dividend
over there so if I have 3x cubed minus x
squared plus 7x minus 4 okay I can
divide this by something larger than
just a linear factor I can divide by
something safer reads up all quadratic
that has a higher power just like this
has a higher value over here friends and
more digits okay so let's try to keep it
nice and simple let's divide by x
squared plus 2x plus 2 okay now a
greater degree of difficulty here so I
did that oh you have to think very
carefully even with these ones over here
I was just going through and talking and
it's easy to mess up the minus signs and
you've got just got more places for this
to go wrong but at least the one thing
that's nice about this is the process is
still the same right strategy will still
work out of all of these terms in the
divisor which is the most important one
so the x squared if the leading term is
that's why we introduce language like
this so we can quickly say it's that one
right so I asked how many x squared
terms fit in here 3x of them okay and so
I go back and I do the same process I'm
now gonna multiply through doing it
carefully 3x cubed
6x squared 6x good thumbs up if it is
right it's literally okay I'm gonna do
my subtraction now that cancels out as
it should - x squared minus 6x squared
is minus 7x squared this also comes
along for the ride that's going to be
plus X and then take away 4 okay all
right back again how many X Squared's
are in there where is 7 yeah oh by the
way notice something that's happened
right before I even write down the next
line what's up here what's happened to
the cushion it's a it's it's a linear
thing isn't it
hold on think about that right when you
took a cubic degree 3 u divided by
degree 1 you ended up with degree 2 well
well this makes sense doesn't it if you
take 2 degree 3 and you divide by degree
2 instead you shouldn't end up with
degree 1 that's just index laws isn't it
ok all right just keep that in your mind
let's continue multiply back minus 7x
squared minus 14x minus 14 yes okay
subtraction these cancel
double negative 15 X plus 10 okay now
here's the next thing I want to notice
so just by increasing the level of the
complexity of this question a little bit
there's more interesting things to
observe how many x squared terms fit
into this none just like no X terms fit
into here right no x squared terms of
into here it's already too small so this
whole object 15 X plus 10 that is the
remainder when you can't divide anymore
oh I can't fit 20 more 27 s into
whatever I end up with then that's what
your remainder is right well I can't fit
anymore X Squared's in this so that
whole thing there
is the remainder okay so we can actually
generalize a really important point here
which many students sort of they're lost
on this because they do so much of this
like 95% of the time you're doing
polynomial division will be by linear
factors also explain more why later but
when you divide by ones that aren't
linear here's how I would generalize
this okay when dividing by a polynomial
of degree n so we've mostly been
dividing by polynomials of degree one
but we just tried dividing by the
polynomial of degree two right when
dividing by Apollinaire with degree n
the remainder is a polynomial with what
degree think about it degree one divisor
gave you a remainder of degree look at
it zero there's just no actual X terms
on it well is that X to the zero - when
your / degree - you end up with a
remainder degree one so the polynomial
remainder we'll have is a polynomial
with degree always one less always one
less and minus one yes so that's that
yes however just generally speaking this
is it's the biggest it can get so if you
come over here right but I say it ah
let's divide twenty one thousand five by
twenty seven the remainder will be less
than twenty seven do you agree
like that's the biggest it can possibly
be okay so when we talk about remainders
in polynomials if you do by divide by a
quadratic then the remainder the biggest
it can be is going to be linear if I
divide it by a cubic good lord I hope
you never ever have to divide by a key
but if I did then I would expect that
the remainder would have a maximum
degree
of two that make sense or one less